FOURTH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO
MONDAY THE SENATE SESSION IT
WILL GET STARTED TO SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ARCHULETA ATTENDEES BACKER
FORTRESS BRADFORD CABALLERO
CORTEZ HE DODD DORADO EGGMAN
GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE HERTZBERG
WESTERN HER TADO JONES KAMLAGER
LAYERED LEYVA THE MON MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ NEWMAN NIELSEN THE
TELEVOTE. PAN PORTANTINO RALPH
RUBIO SKINNER STERN AMBERG WHITE
HOUSE SKI WIENER WILK. GOOD
AFTERNOON LADIES AND GENTLEMEN A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WE CAN GET
STARTED WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR
GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE I'M
SORRY. WILL BE LED IN PRAYER
THIS AFTERNOON BY CENTER DORADO
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING IN WILL BE LED THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. BY THE FOR
THE TO THE FLAG BY SENATOR
NEWMAN. CENTER DRAWS UP THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT. OUR FATHER
HOLY MOTHER CREATOR OF THE
COSMOS SOURCE OF LIFE. YOU WERE
IN MY MIND IN MY GARDEN MY CUP
OF WINE. AND LOAF OF BREAD.
BLESSED BE YOUR NAME'S MOTHER
ALLAH GODDESS BELOVED GREAT
SPIRIT RADIANT ONE. YEAH AWAY HI
SHAM SOPHIA. YOUR PRESENCE HAS
COME YOU WILL IS DONE ON EARTH
AS IT IS IN THE COSMOS MAY WE
GIVE EACH OTHER STRENGTH MERCY
TENDERNESS AND JOY. WHEN WE
FORGIVE THE INCOMPLETENESS IN
EACH OTHER. IT IS HOME TO THE
MYSTERY OF OURSELVES TO CLARITY
TO ONE THIS AND DELIVER US FROM
THE SHADOWS OF OUR IGNORANCE AND
FEAR. SO WE PRAY AND SO WE
RECEIVE AMON. CALAIS'S PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. THANK YOU
SENATORS RAZA NEWMAN. MEMBERS
TODAY WE HAVE SENATORS BATES
DALLY AND MEN PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS
. MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
WILL BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES
FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES IS THERE ANY MEMBERS
WISHING TO BE RECOGNIZED UNDER
MOTIONS. SEEING NONE WE'RE GONNA
GO TO THE INTRODUCTION AND FIRST
READING OF BILLS SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILLS
867-868-8698 SEVENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY ONE AND SENATE BILL
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO. THANK YOU
MA'AM SIR TERRY WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE SENATE JOURNALS
FOR THE WEEK OF JANUARY EIGHTEEN
THROUGH TWENTY. TWENTY TO TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WILL BE APPROVED AND
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO THE SENATE THIRD READING NOW. WHICH ANY. MEMBERS RIGHT TAKE
UP FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE TO
BEGIN THE DAY SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. I'M SORRY STAND BY. SO I
MEMBERS WANT TO GO BACK TO
SECOND READING AT THE SECRETARY
CAN PLEASE READ SECOND READING.
SENATE BILL. 323-364-4676 TWENTY
SIX FORTY ONE FIVE SEVENTY NINE
AND SENATE BILL TWO THIRTEEN.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA MOVE TO THIRD
READING WE HAVE- SEVENTEEN OR SO
BILLS WE'RE GONNA GET THROUGH
THIS AFTERNOON. IF WE CAN ALL BE
PREPARED TO GET READY. WE'RE
GONNA START WITH FILE ITEM
THIRTY THREE. THE SECRETARY CAN
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FIFTY
FOUR BY SENATOR ALAN AN ACT
RELATING TO SOLID WASTE. CENTER
ALLEN.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON A FILE ITEM THIRTY
FIVE. SENATOR SKINNER. MEMBERS
WERE GONNA START VOTING HERE
PRETTY SOON. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL SEVEN FORTY SIX
BY SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT
RELATING TO PRIVACY. OUR CENTER
SKINNER YOU HAVE THE FLOOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SB SEVEN FOUR SIX. DEALS
WITH A FIVE ISSUE THAT WOULDN'T
HAVE BEEN ANTICIPATED WHEN WE
DEVELOPED EITHER OUR POLITICAL
REPORTING LAWS OR EVEN WHEN WE
DEVELOPED OUR- HE SAID OUR
PRIVACY. OFFICE THAT DEALS WITH
THE PRIVACY WITH THAT WE HAVE
NOW PROVIDED FOR CONSUMERS THE
VOTERS HAVE THROUGH THE
INITIATIVE THAT PASSED JUST A
COUPLE YEARS AGO. AND WHAT IS B.
FORTY SIX DEALS WITH IS THE FACT
THAT THERE IS THE ABILITY FOR.
ONLINE COMPANIES INTERNET
COMPANIES TO. IN EFFECT AS
RENO'S WITHDREW ALGORITHMS OR
OTHERWISE CURATE CONTENT. NOW
CURATING OF CONTENT IS NOT PER
SE THE PROBLEM HERE BUT IT JUST
RATHER YES. THEY ARE INSERTING
OR- OR AMY. TOWARDS A PARTICULAR
POLITICAL POSITION AND
PURPOSEFULLY DOING SO THAT WE
HAVE NO WAY FOR THE CONSUMER TO
KNOW THAT IT IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT IS REPORTABLE FOR EXAMPLE
TO OUR FEAR POLITICAL CAMPAIGN
PRACTICES SO IT IS IN EFFECT A-
POLITICAL ACTIVITY OR CAMPAIGN
ACTIVITY. WHICH IS NOW NOT
REPORTABLE SO THE BILL IS
CURRENTLY STRUCTURED WOULD GIVE
THIS RESPONSIBILITY FOR
COMPANIES TO DISCLOSE THAT THEY
ARE DOING THIS TO OUR- CONSUMER
PRIVACY. OFFICE HOWEVER WORKING
WITH THE VARIOUS ENTITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT THE
BILL FIVE AGREED TO AMEND THE
BILL IN THE ASSEMBLY TO CHANGE
IT SO THAT INSTEAD THIS
INFORMATION IS PROVIDED TO THE
F. PPC AND IT REMOVES THEN THE
PRIVACY OFFICE SO THE BILL IS
BEFORE YOU YES YOU WERE TAKING A
LEAP OF FAITH AND I WOULD ASK
THAT YOU VOTE YES THAT YOU WOULD
BE VOTING ON A BILL TODAY THAT
LEAVES IT IN THE PRIVACY OFFICE
HOWEVER. I WILL AMENDED AND YOU
HAVE MY WORD TO MAKE IT TO PAY
REPORTING TO THE FAIR POLITICAL
PRACTICES COMMISSION AND- THAT
WILL ADDRESS THE MAJOR CONCERNS
OF THE OPPOSITION ENDED BEING WE
JUST CAN WORK OUT AN WITH. I
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR SKINNER MEMBERS
ANY DISK OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM
. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS I BAKER ARE
YOU FOR JUST. BRADFORD CABALLERO
I PROTECTING AYE DODD. I TORONTO
I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER. GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG FIVE WESSEL
HI BRITTONUM. JONES NO KAMLAGER
. I LAYERED I LEYVA I LIMON I
MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ. NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. BUT SHOW A VOTE. NO PAN
AYE PORTANTINO I ROTH HI RUBIO.
HI SKINNER AYE STERN. I'M BURKE
I CASTING AYE WIENER AYE WILK.
NO. REMOVE A CALL WE ARE MEMBERS
GOING BACK TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
THREE SENATOR ALLEN IS READY.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FIFTY FOUR BY SENATOR ALAN
AN ACT RELATING TO SOLID WASTE.
SENATOR ALAN. I THANK YOU SO
MUCH MR PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS SO
SB FIFTY FOUR IS A REFINEMENT OF
LAST SESSION'S BILL BY THE
NUMBER I DESIGNED TO REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF DISPOSABLE SINGLE USE
PACKAGING AND FOOD WASTE THAT
BURDENS TAXPAYER. PLEASE HIM.
INTERMENT WE'RE VERY FAMILIAR
WITH THE FACTS LESS THAN 50% OF
SINGLE USE PLASTIC IS RECYCLED
NEARLY EVERY PIECE OF PLASTIC
EVER PRODUCED STIL EXISTS IN
LANDFILLS OR THE GENERAL
ENVIRONMENT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO SPEND
UPWARDS OF HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR. HAPPEN FOR. ST
STE PARKSON WHY. THAT MEANS A
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE CONTINUE
TO RAISE GARBAGE AND RECYCLING
RATES TO KEEP UP WITH THE COST
OF MANAGING OFFICE MODESTO
CALIFORNIANS WANT A SOLUTION TO
THIS ISSUE AND OUR GOAL WITH
THIS BILL IS TO ESTABLISH A
COMPREHENSIVE FRAMEWORK TO
ADDRESS THIS COSTLY PROBLEM WE
KNOW IT'S A TOUGH ISSUE THAT'S
WHY I'VE SPENT THREE AND A HALF
YEARS NOW WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. ARE BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD WE MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS ARE EITHER THIS IS THIS
IS I DO I DO SINCERELY BELIEVE
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO CROSS THE
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM THAT
ACHIEVES OUR GOALS A BILL THAT
WILL BE FLEXIBLE ENOUGH TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS RAISED BY END.
BUT STRONG ENOUGH TO WIN THE
SUPPORT ENVIRONMENTAL AND
BUSINESS GROUPS THAT HAVE
QUALIFIED STATEWIDE BALLOT IN
THIS. HEY DID YOU HEAR. GO OVER
THE SOMEBODY TO CONTINUE THE
ROBUST. IF THE BILL COMES BACK
TO THE SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE IT
WILL HAVE THE SUPPORT OF
SIGNIFICANT INDUSTRY INDUSTRY
GROUP AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY OR THE ISSUE WILL
SIMPLY GET RESOLVED AT THE
BALLOT BOX IN NOVEMBER. AND IT'S
WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING. THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU CENTER ALLEN MEMBERS
WE ARE ON FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE
SENATE BILL FIFTY FOUR. WE'RE IN
MY- DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SENATOR GLAZER YOUR RECOGNIZE.
AND TO SPACE MAKES US IN AROUND
CAN YOU- ALLOW CENTER GLAZER
ACCESS TO MICROPHONE THERE
PLEASE. WHERE YOU HAVE SENATOR
GLAZER AND THEN SENATOR RUBIO
SENATOR GLAZERS YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF- SB FIFTY FOUR ON.
THE REASONS THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
MADE CLEAR IF SINGLE USE
PLASTICS ARE A SERIOUS PROBLEM
THAT WE HAVE TO. FIND A PATHWAY
TO. DEALING WITH I WANT TO SAY
THAT. I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SEE CENTER ALLEN. I HAD HIS
WORK WITH- ALL SIDES AND TRYING
TO FIND COMMON GROUND IN THIS
SPACE. AND I THINK THAT I'VE
BEEN ENCOURAGED BY THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK WITH ALL
BOTH SIDES AS WELL AND FEEL LIKE
THERE'S A CONSTRUCTIVE
ENGAGEMENT THAT I ONLY WANT TO
SEE CONTINUE. WITH IT THE BILL
AS A POTENTIAL VEHICLE SO I WANT
TO THANK SENATOR ALAN FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP IN THE SPACE IN
IMPORTANT. LEADERSHIP AND HOPE
THAT- HIS WORK IN THE ASSEMBLY
CAN CONTINUE TO BE FRUITFUL AND
WE CAN HAVE ABILITY SUGGEST THAT
COMES BACK. WHERE EVERYONE HAS
FOUND THE RIGHT COMMON GROUND TO
THE- HAVE OUR PLANET SO WITH
THAT I. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NINE BILLION SB FIFTY FOUR THANK
YOU SENATOR GLAZERS SENATOR
RUBIO. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- I
RISE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL BUT I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO FOR SO I THINK THE AUTHOR I
KNOW HE'S BEEN WORKING FOR THREE
YEARS AND A HALF. ON THIS BILL
IN PARTICULAR TO BRING ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER WHICH IS I
THINK IT'S A LITTLE RARE TO
SPEND THAT MUCH TIME AND HE'S
DONE SO- YOU KNOW SO WILLINGLY
SO I ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO THE
FINAL PRODUCT BUT CLEARLY WE
HAVE A PROBLEM THERE IS AN ISSUE
A HAND. AND I BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL WILL HELP US GET THERE BUT
I DO AGAIN LOOK FOR TO SEE WHAT
THE OUTCOME OF THIS BILL S.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO WE'RE GONNA GO TO CENTER
HERTZBERG AND THEN SENATOR
HUESO. SENATOR HERTZBERG YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU OF. MISTER
PRESIDENT I JUST WANT TO. SAY IN
THE NEW ROLE THAT THE PRO TEM
HAS ASSIGNED ME TO IN THIS JOB
IS EMERITUS TO DEAL WITH ISSUES.
THAT INTEGRATE BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE. AND THE BALLOT
MEASURE AND PARTICULARLY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH CENTER
ALLEN OTHERS IF THAT COULD BE OF
ANY HELP IN THAT REGARD IT WOULD
SURE BE GREAT. IF WE COULD REACH
A COMPROMISE THAT WOULD IMPACT
THE BALLOT AS WE HAVE A CREEK
POTENTIALLY A VERY CROWDED
BALLOTS SO I AM. VERY EXCITED TO
EVEN HAVE ENTERTAINED THE
THOUGHT OF BEING ABLE TO DO
THAT. AND TO THANK US CENTER
ALLEN FOR HIS EXTRAORDINARY
DILIGENCE AND- WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH EVERYBODY ON THIS AND
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE TODAY SUCH THANK YOU
SIR. THANK YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG
SENATOR HUESO. THANK YOU I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE PLASTICS AND THE
PROLIFERATION PROBLEM PLASTICS
IN THE ENVIRONMENT. OR A GROWING
PROBLEM A GROWING CONCERN WE
DEFINITELY NEED TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT. THE BILL IS A SOMEWHAT
SILENT ON COMPOSTABLE PRODUCTS
THERE ARE PLASTIC PRODUCTS THAT
ARE MADE BY BIODEGRADABLE.
MATERIAL THAT ARE- COMPOSTABLE
VERY QUICKLY. AND I WOULD LIKE
TO ENCOURAGE THAT INDUSTRY TO
TAKE OFF TO GROW TO OFFER AN
ALTERNATIVE TO CONSUMERS. TO
HAVE OF. A PRODUCT THAT THEY CAN
USE- IT'S STILL GOING TO BE A
PORN FOR CONSUMERS TO HAVE
REPLACEMENT PRODUCTS FOR THESE-
OTHER PRODUCTS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXTREMELY- UNTIL TERRACE ON THE
ENVIRONMENT SO- I'D LIKE TO ASK
HIM. TO PLEASE MAKE A COMMITMENT
TO WORK TOWARD- EXEMPT THE IN-
BIODEGRADABLE PRODUCTS AND
ALLOWING THE MONTH MARKET TO
CONTINUE TO TRY TO INTRODUCE
THOSE AND GIVE CONSUMERS A
CHOICE. THANK YOU CENTER WAS SO
SENATOR BECKER IN THE CENTER BY
CASKEY SENATOR VICTOR. THANK AYE
AYES ARISES PLEASE BILL WHICH
WENT TO. MAKE A NOTE ABOUT THE
NEXUS WITH PLASTICS AND CLIMATE
CHANGES MADE IN THE NOTES THAT
IN TWENTY NINETEEN GLOBAL
PLASTIC PRODUCTION FROM
EXTRACTION TO RESIN PRODUCTION.
YEAH AN INDUSTRIAL SITUATION
ALONE AT THE SAME AMOUNT OF
GREENHOUSE GASES TO THE
ATMOSPHERE AT NEARLY A HUNDRED
NINETY. FIVE HUNDRED MEGAWATT
COAL PLANTS SO. TWENTY TO MAKE
THAT A NEXUS VERY CLEAR AND-
SUPPORTIVE OF THE EFFORTS THAT
TO YOU- FIND A SOLUTION HERE
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR. THANK
YOU CENTER BAKER CENTER BY CAL
SKI. MR PRESIDENT I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE THIS
EXCITING OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA WANTSTO. ONCE AGAIN
TO LEAD IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL.
ARENA THIS IS A LONG TIME COMING
I APPLAUD THE EFFORTS BY THE-
MAJORITY LEADER AMERITAS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE- WE DEAL WITH THIS
AND THE LEGISLATIVE. ARENA AS
WELL AS MY COLLEAGUE WHO IS A
FROM SAN DIEGO WHO IS TALKING
ABOUT COMPOSABLE WE'RE WE'RE
DOING A LOUSY JOB. WITH
MANAGEMENT OF OUR WASTE WE'VE
GOT 20% OF OUR METHANE. PROBLEM
COMES FROM OUR LANDFILLS WE'VE
GOT TO DO IS GONNA BE ALL HANDS
ON DECK TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
STUFF. THAT GOES INTO- THE
LANDFILLS AND WE START WITH THE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY THAT HAS THESE
PRODUCTS EITHER COMPOSTABLE. OR
THEIR REVIEWS IT'S A NEW AGENDA
WE OWE IT TO OUR KIDS OUR
GRANDKIDS AND CALIFORNIA WILL
LEAD. WITH AN AYE VOTE ON SB
FIFTY FOUR. THANK YOU CENTER BY
CASKEY ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. ON FILE ITEM THIRTY
THREE. CENTER CALM WATER. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I WAS GOING TO
SAY ANYTHING BECAUSE I AM A
PROUD CO AUTHOR BUT I JUST RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THE
SENATOR FROM SANTA MONICA HAS
BEEN WORKING HARD FOR THREE
YEARS AND A HALF TO GET THIS
BILL PASSED AND WE ACTUALLY-
IT'S- TO CALIFORNIA. TO GET THIS
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE AS- MY
COLLEAGUE JUST MENTIONED ABOUT
THE CIRCULAR ECONOMY AND HAVING
ALL OF THIS WASTE GOING TO
LANDFILLS THE REALITY IS THAT WE
DON'T GET OUR ACT TOGETHER ALL
OF THAT WAY SO IT'S GOING INTO
THE LANDFILLS IS EVENTUALLY
GOING TO FIND ITS WAY INTO OUR
BODIES SO IF WE CARE ABOUT OUR
BODIES AND THE BODIES OF OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE. COMING BEHIND US
WE SHOULD BE FIGURING OUT THIS
ISSUE. PLASTICS ARE GOING TO END
UP. EVERYWHERE CHOKING TO DEATH
AND I KNOW THAT SOUNDS EXTREME
BUT IF YOU READ THE DATA THAT'S
OUT THERE AND WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN OUR OCEANS AND WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THE PROTEIN THAT
WE ARE GROWING AND HARVESTING ON
OUR LANDS WE HAVE GOT TO GET OUR
ACT TOGETHER AS IT RELATES TO
PLASTICS AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE
HI ON THIS BILL. EACH TIME YOU
SEE IT. THANK YOU CENTER
KAMLAGER ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ANYMORE
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE CENTER ALAN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THE COMMENTS HE
MADE IN AND FOR ALL THE INPUT
AND FEEDBACK WE'VE BEEN GETTING
THROUGH THIS PROCESS I DO WANT
TO I WANT TO YOU KNOW THE
ANSWERING THE QUESTION OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO. THAT'S
ACTUALLY BEEN AT THE HEART OF
THE BILL THE FOCUS IS ON IS ON-
YOU KNOW ON ON ON ON BIODEGRADE
ABILITY COMPOST ABILITY AND
REUSABILITY RECYCLABILITY. AND
AND SO WE ARE ABSOLUTELY
INTERESTED IN HELPING TO PROMOTE
AND ENCOURAGE THOSE ITEMS THAT
ARE A SUBSTITUTE FOR TRADITIONAL
PLASTIC ITEMS THAT REALLY ARE
TRULY BIODEGRADABLE TRULY ARE
COMPOSTABLE THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
WE NEED- AND SO I'M I'M I'M I'M
CERTAINLY JUST IN WORKING WITH
HIM AND OTHERS ON ON INSURING
THAT THAT- THAT THAT THOSE KINDS
OF PRODUCTS ARE ARE ARE AND
HELPED ALONG BY THIS BILL. IT'S
BEEN A LONG JOURNEY CONTINUES TO
BE A LONG JOURNEY AS YOU KNOW A
VERY POPULAR ABOUT MEASURES
QUALIFY FOR THE BALLOT- THE
QUESTION NOW IS CAN WE STRIKE A
DEAL HERE IN THIS LEGISLATURE
THAT WILL SATISFY. THE NEEDS OF
BUSINESS WHILE ALSO SATISFYING
THE NEEDS AND CONCERNS OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY THEY
WOULD FEEL. PULLING A MEASURE IN
. AVOIDING INCREDIBLE COSTLY
RATHER IN. FIGHT COMING OVER- SO
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS A- GIVING US
UP. TO GET THIS DEAL STRUCK.
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES ARE
SUPPORT FOR THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. THANK YOU CENTER ALLEN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
FIVE BAKER HI FORTUS. NO
BRADFORD. CABALLERO ARE YOU
PROTESTING I DODD I TORONTO HI
EGGMAN I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI WESTERN. I
FURTADO I JONES NO KAMLAGER I
LAYERED HI LEYVA HI LIMON I
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ NO NEWMAN.
I NIELSEN NO CONTROL OF BOTH NO
HAN. I PORTANTINO AYE ROTH I
RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN HI I'M
BURKE HI WE CASTING AYE WIENER
AYE WILK NO. SECULAR PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD
GROVE NOW. IS TWENTY NINE KNOWS
SEVEN MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON A FILE ITEM
THIRTY SIX THIRTY SEVEN AND THEN
FORTY FOUR. LIVING RIGHT NOW TO
FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX THE
SENATOR- BURKE. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ANNABELLE THIRTY FOUR BY
SENATOR UMBERG AN ACTIVE
RELATING TO LIBRARIES AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE AT
SIX FOR TO MEDIALLY CENTER
NUMBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT SB THIRTY FOUR
BILL THAT WOULD IMPROVE
LITERACY- PARTICULARLY IN TIMES
LIKE THESE WHEN ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET MAY BE CHALLENGING WHAT
IT DOES IS IT PROVIDES THAT
LIBRARIES CAN PROVIDE. IN
CONJUNCTION WITH SCHOOL DISTRICT
LIBRARY CARDS TO ALL STUDENTS OF
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND LIVE
REDUCERS CAN COMPETE FOR GRANTS
MAKE THIS AVAILABLE URGENT AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SARAH BURKE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FILE
ITEM THIRTY FIVE SIX. SENATE
BILL THIRTY FOUR. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BAKER.
ARE YOU FOR JUST. BRADFORD BY
ADAM I CORTES EATEN AYE DODD.
FIVE ZERO SEVEN I EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER I GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO. I JONES NO KAMLAGER. I
LAYERED. I LEYVA HI THE MON AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ. NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I PATROL BOAT NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
HI SKINNER I STERN HI I'M BURKE
HI MY COUNTY I WIENER AYE WILK
NO. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. PORGES BRADFORD
GROSS NO MELENDEZ. IS THIRTY
KNOWS FOR ON THE URGENCY HIGHS
THIRTY KNOWS FOR ON THE MEASURE
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM- THIRTY
SEVEN I ALSO SENATOR UMBERG ON
SB FORTY NINE CENTER ON BURKE
I'M SORRY SECRETARY PLEASE READ
THE- SENATE- FORTY NINE BY
SENATOR UMBERG AN ACT RELATING
TO TAXATION TO TAKE OVER TO
NEARLY TAX LEVY. NOW CENTER
NUMBER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBER BILL SIMPLY PROVIDES A
TAX CREDIT TO REIMBURSE SMALL
BUSINESSES FOR STATE LOCAL FEES
PAID DURING THE COVE IN INETEEN
PANDEMIC AND FOR FEES PAID
DURING FUTURE EMERGENCIES THAT
MAY RESULT IN GOVERNMENT ORDERS
CLOSE BUSINESSES AYE ARJUN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER AMBERG
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN
. SEEING NONE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BAKER I
PORCHES. I BRADFORD CABALLERO I
PROTECTING I DODD. ARE YOU THERE
ARE CERTAIN I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER
. I GONZALEZ I WROTE I HERTZBERG
I WAS SO. HI FOR TIGER I JONES I
KAMLAGER. I CLEARED HI LEYVA AYE
THE MON. HI MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ
AYE NEWMAN I NIELSEN AYE BUT
SHOW A VOTE I PAN. I PORTANTINO
. I ROTH. I RUBIO. HI SKINNER I
STERN I NUMBER I WHITE HOUSE SKI
I WIENER. I WILL. I. HIGHS
THIRTY SIX KNOWS ZERO MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WERE GOING TO
SKIP FILE I'M FORTY FOUR FOR A
MINUTE WE'RE GOING TO GO TO FILE
ITEM FORTY SEVEN AND WE CAN MOVE
THE FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN
SENATORS STERN ON S. B. TWO
NINETY ONE. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL TWO NINETY ONE
BY SENATOR STERN AN ACT RELATING
TO SPECIAL EDUCATION. SENATOR
STERN YOU HAVE THE FLOOR. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MY COMING
THROUGH OKAY. OKAY THANK YOU
TURNING TO BE BACK ON THE FLOOR
WITH YOU ALL AND TO PRESENT THIS
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
HERE TO GIVE STUDENTS A VOICE
ACT WOULD ADD ONE STUDENT MEMBER
TO THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
EDUCATION ADVISORY COUNCIL-
BILLS NO OPPOSITION BUT WORK
BEARS MENTIONING THAT OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND YOUNG PEOPLE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA RECEIVE
SPECIAL EDUCATION SOMEONE HAS
OVER 12% OF OUR STUDENT
POPULATION THEY'VE GONE THROUGH
A- COUPLE YEARS. WE THINK THEY
NEED TO BOYS ON THEIR OWN
ACCOUNTS THE HUMBLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTING THE STUDENTS A VOICE.
THANK YOU CENTER STERN MEMBERS
ANY OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE MEMBERS THIS
QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NO OBJECTION
IS THIRTY SIX KNOWS ZERO MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS ARE NOW MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM FIFTY. WHICH IS
SENATOR CABALLERO ON SENATE BILL
FOUR NINETY. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL FOUR NINETY BY
SENATOR CABALLERO AN ACT
RELATING TO HOUSING. CENTER
COMING UP THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SB FOUR
NINETY AN IMPORTANT BILL TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
ACQUIRE AND PRESERVE MUCH NEEDED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. THE BILL CREASY
ACQUISITION AND REHAB TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT THE
PROGRAM WOULD PROVIDE EXPERTISE
AND BUILD CAPACITY FOR MISSION
DRIVEN ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL
HOUSING AGENCIES ENGAGED TO GROW
AND STRENGTHEN LOCAL ACQUISITION
OR- OR REHAB PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. THE LARGE MAJORITY
OF LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS LIVE
IN SUBSIDIZED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WHICH IS HOUSING THAT IS
PRIVATELY OWNED THAT IS
AFFORDABLE TO LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS DUE TO A VARIETY OF
REASONS THE LACK OF SUPPLY AND
GROWING DEMAND THIS UNSUBSIDIZED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS RAPIDLY
DISAPPEARING. PUSHING PEOPLE OUT
OF THEIR HOMES AND COMMUNITY AS
IS HOUSING STOCK DISAPPEARS
THERE ARE FEWER AND FEWER PLACES
FOR LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS TO
LIVE IN WE'VE SEEN AS DURING
THIS CORONAVIRUS- PANDEMIC. IN
RESPONSE TO THIS LOSS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING LOCAL
COMMUNITIES IN BEGUN TO ACQUIRE
UNSUBSIDIZED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND PRESERVING IT. AS OF A
PERMANENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DIRECT ACQUISITION REHAB. ACT
REHAB INCREASES THE SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING QUICKLY AND
IN A COST EFFECTIVE WAY HOWEVER
EVEN FOR EXPERIENCED DEVELOPERS
AND COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS THIS
NEW TO OF PRESERVATION. SENSE OF
RIDING OF NUKE. CHALLENGE BRING
ON THE SUCCESS OF OTHER STATE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS SB
FOUR NINETY WILL ADDRESS THE
CHINA BY PROVIDING THE NECESSARY
EXPERTISE AND CAPACITY BUILDING
FOR ELIGIBLE ORGANIZATIONS SUCH
AS AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST LOCAL
HOUSING AGENCY AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATIONS THE
BILL ENJOYS NO OPPOSITION A
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU CENTER COME
HERE MEMBERS WERE ON FILE ITEM
FIFTY SENATE BILL FOUR NINETY IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MEMBERS
THIS ALSO QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NO OBJECTION HIGHS THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS%
STICKING WITH CENTER CABALLERO
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
FIFTY ONE. SENATE BILL FIVE
THIRTY TWO SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY TWO BY
SENATOR CABALLERO AN ACT
RELATING TO PEOPLE INSTRUCTION.
CENTER CABALLERO THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT SB FIVE THIRTY TWO WHICH
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
HIGHLY MOBILE STUDENTS TO
RECEIVE A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA.
CHILDREN IN THE MILITARY ARE
MIGRANT FAMILIES FOSTER CARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
WARDS OF THE COURT AND NEWCOMERS
TO THE COUNTRY ARE CONSIDERED
HIGHLY MOBILE STUDENTS THE
STUDENTS ARE INCREDIBLY
VULNERABLE TO EDUCATIONAL
DISRUPTIONS IN CHALLENGING
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT HAVE BECOME
FURTHER ACT EXACERBATED BECAUSE
OF CODE NINETEEN. THIS BILL
REDUCES THE BARRIERS TO
RECEIVING A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA
BY AMENDING THE EDUCATION CODE
EXEMPT HIGHLY MOBILE STUDENTS
FROM A LOCAL GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS IF IT IS REASONABLY
BE DETERMINED THAT THEY CAN
COMPLETE THE REQUIREMENTS WITHIN
A FIFTH YEAR OF SCHOOL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU CENTER CARNEIRO ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MEMBERS THIS ALSO
QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NO OBJECTION I
IS THIRTY SIX NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES WE'RE ALSO GONNA STICK
AGAIN WITH SENATOR CABALLERO ON
FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO. SENATE BILL
THREE EIGHTY TWO SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL THREE
EIGHTY TWO BY SENATOR CABALLERO
AND AFTER RELATING TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. CENTER CABALLERO.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
SENATORS I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
SB THREE EIGHTY TWO WHICH WOULD
CLARIFY IN CASES WHERE A SEXUAL
PREDATOR IS CRIMINALLY CHARGED
WITH THE COMMERCIAL SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION OF A MINOR. A
RESTRAINING ORDER SHOULD BE
ROUTINELY REQUESTED TO PROHIBIT
THE PREDATOR FROM CONTACTED
CONTACTING THE EXPLOITED MINOR.
ESTIMATES BY THE INTERNATIONAL
LABOR ORGANIZATION REPORTED
THERE ARE CLOSE TO TWENTY FIVE
MILLION INDIVIDUALS BEING
TRAFFICKED WORLDWIDE AND FOR
PART POINT EIGHT MILLION OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE VICTIMS OF
SEXUAL EXPLOITATION. EXPERTS
BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCES THE MOST CHILD
TRAFFICKING IN THE UNITED STATES
DUE TO OUR BUSY PORTS HOWEVER
IT'S HARD TO KNOW EXACTLY HOW
MANY CHILDREN ARE VICTIMS. WHEN
AN EXPLOITER OF THE MINOR IS
EXPOSED TO CRIMINAL CHARGES ARE
IS EXPOSED INTERNAL CARD
CRIMINAL CHARGES ARE BROUGHT A
SMALL OVERSIGHT OFTEN OCCURS THE
CAN HAVE DIRE CONSEQUENCES
RESTRAINING ORDERS ARE NOT
ROUTINELY REQUESTED DURING
CRIMINAL CASES. AND AS A
CONSEQUENCE THE EXPORTER HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTACT THE CHILD
KEEPING CHILDREN AWAY FROM THEIR
EXPORTERS IT'S A LIFE AND DEATH
MATTER. AS THE AVERAGE LIFE
EXPECTANCY OF EXPERT AN
EXPLOITED CHILD IS ONLY SEVEN
YEARS DUE TO THE HIGH INCIDENCE
OF HOMICIDE DRUG OVERDOSE HIV
AIDS AND OTHER STDS. SB THREE
EIGHTY TWO IS A SIMPLE CHANGE TO
GIVE COMMERCIAL. VERIFY THE
CURRENT LAW PERMITS AND SET
STANDARDS FOR THESE ORDERS AS
PART OF THE CRIMINAL PROCEEDINGS
. AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY- COMMITTEE REMOVED
ALL UP OPPOSITION THANK YOU AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU SIR CABALLERO MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE THIS ALSO
QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE HIGHS
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES CENTER COVER HERO IS
STILL UP TO BAT GOING FOR. THE
SLAM. ON ITEM FIFTY THREE SENATE
BILL FIVE FIFTY EIGHT CENTS A
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FIVE FIFTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
CABALLERO AN ACT RELATING TO
FARMWORKERS SENATOR CARDIO THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT PLEASED TO
PRESENT SB FIVE FIFTY EIGHT
WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH THE
FARMWORKER DISASTER RELIEF
PLANNING TASK FORCE. WITHIN
CALLAWAY YES TO PREPARE FOR THE
NEEDS OF FARMWORKERS THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEIR COMMUNITIES
FOR IMMEDIATE AND LONG TERM
SUSTAINABLE AND EQUITABLE ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE SAFETY NET
SERVICES AND OTHER SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC RELIEF DURING NATURAL
DISASTERS AND- AND PANDEMICS WE
ALL KNOW THAT. FARMWORKERS AMONG
THE HARDEST WORKERS. IN THE
STATE AND QUITE FRANKLY WITH THE
SERIES OF DISASTERS THAT WE HAVE
WHETHER IT'S BEEN WILD FIRES ARE
PANDEMIC FARMWORKERS WERE
WORKING DURING ALL OF THAT TIME
AND SO THIS- WOULD SET UP AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO HAVE SOME
ADVANCE PLANNING SO WE KNOW HOW
TO BE ABLE TO. ISSUE ADVISORIES
PASS OUT- MATERIALS AND MAKE
SURE THAT TEY CAN BE SAFE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR
CABALLERO MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON FILE ITEM. FIFTY
THREE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BAKER. I FOR JUST AYE
BRADFORD CABALLERO I PROTECTING
AYE DODD HI TORONTO I EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER. I GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. I
FURTADO I JONES HI KAMLAGER I
LAYERED I LEYVA. FIVE LIMON HI
MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ. NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN AYE A CELLO BOW I PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. I RUBIO
I SKINNER I STERN HI I'M BURKE
HI MY COUNTY I WIENER AYE WILK
AYE THIS CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
. BRADFORD MELENDEZ I. FIVE
THIRTY SIX NOES ZERO MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE. WHICH IS
CENTER MCGUIRE N SB THREE OH
SEVEN. SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL THREE OH SEVEN BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AN ACT RELATING
TO TRANSPORTATION SENATE MCGUIRE
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON SB
THREE OH SEVEN IS A CRITICAL
BILL THAT SEEKS TO STOP ON THE
LARGEST ENVIRONMENTAL THREATS AT
THIS STATE AND THE NORTH COAST
IS SEEN. IN DECADES THIS
PROPOSAL FROM A CLANDESTINE
OPERATION HIDING BEHIND
ANONYMOUS LLC OUT OF WYOMING
ONCE A SHIP LITERALLY MILLIONS
UPON MILLIONS OF TONS OF COAL
THROUGH THE MIDDLE OF CALIFORNIA
THROUGH THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA THEN UP INTO NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO THE COUNTIES OF
SONOMA AND MARIN. MENDOCINO AS
WELL AS TRINITY IN HUMBLE
COUNTY'S THE COAL WOULD THEN BE
SOLD OVERSEAS THROUGH THE PORT
OF HUMBLE. THIS BILL WILL
PROTECT CALIFORNIA PREVENTING BY
PREVENTING ALL STATE FUNDING.
FROM GOING TO THIS INITIATIVE.%
IT WOULD NOT ALLOW THESE
OPERATORS TO BE ROOM PROUVER
OPERATE RAIL SERVICE WITH ANY
TYPE OF STATE SUBSIDY NORTH OF
THE CITY WILLITS. FURTHER EIGHT
BAN STATE MONEY FOR BEING SPENT
ON THE BUILD OUT OF ANY NO NEW
BOOK COAL TERMINAL FACILITIES.
AT THE PORT OF HUMBLE IN THE
COUNTY OF HUMBOLDT. JUST WANNA
SAY LASTLY MISTER PRESIDENT THIS
RAIL LINE RUNS ALONG TWO RIVERS
WHICH IS THE DRINKING WATER
SOURCE FOR NEARLY ONE MILLION
FOLKS. IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MCGUIRE MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN FIVE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BAKER
HI FORTUS NO BRADFORD BY ADAM I
PRETENDING I DONT. FIVE THE
RUSSELL I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER.
FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO I JONES I KAMLAGER. I
LAYERED AYE LEYVA HI THE MON HI
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ. NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I SHOW OF BOTH. PAN I
PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER. I STERN HI I'M
BURKE HI WHITE HOUSE HE AYE
WIENER AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD GROVE.
MELENDEZ. WELL CHOI BOGUE NO
WILK. I. WILL MOVE THE CALL.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX FOR A REMOTE
PRESENTATION FROM SENATOR BATES
. FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX IS SENATE
BILL FOR SEVENTY THREE SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FOR
SEVENTY THREE BY SENATOR BATES
AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- SENATE BILL FOR
SEVENTY THREE WILL HELP ADDRESS
THE HIGH TREATMENT COSTS FOR
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS WITH
DIABETES BY PLACING THIRTY FIVE
DOLLARS PER MONTH CAP FOR EACH
DOSAGE FORM OF INSULIN THIS WILL
APPLY TO COPAYS DEDUCTIBLES AND
ANY OTHER COST SHARING
REQUIREMENTS YOU ALSO EXCLUDE
THE EQUIPMENT AND SUPPLIES
NEEDED TO TREAT DIABETES FROM
ANY DEDUCTIBLE. PEOPLE WITH
DIABETES STAND JUDITH THREE
TIMES MORE- ARCH STANDARD TWO TO
THREE TIMES MORE ON HEALTH CARE
EXPENSES THAT A PERSON WITHOUT
THE DISEASE THE AVERAGE PRICE OF
THE BRAND NAME OF INSULIN NEARLY
TRIPLED BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN AND TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
SB FOUR SEVENTY THREE PEOPLE
DIABETES G. MAXIMO CARSHARING
FOR THEIR LIFE SAVING INSULIN
WHICH WILL ALLOW THEM TO FOCUS
ON MANAGING THEIR CHRONIC
CONDITIONS. I RECEIVED A
UNANIMOUS ELEVEN ZERO VOTED NO
COMMITTEE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BAKER.
I PORCHES I BRADFORD BY ADAM
HIGH COURT HEAVY I DON. FIVE
TORONTO I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE. ARE YOU
HERTZBERG I WESTERN I HER TADO I
JONES THANK AYE KAMLAGER. I
WHERE AYE LEYVA. FIVE THE MON
FIVE MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ AYE
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. HI A TROUBLE
I PAN. HI PORTANTINO. HI BROUGH
I RUBIO. FIVE AYE STERN AYE
NUMBERED ALL RIGHT I LIKE HOW
SKI I WIENER AYE WILK. I HIGHS
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON THE
FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE SENATE BILL
FORTY FIVE CENTER PORTANTINO
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL FORTY FIVE BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO AN ACT RELATING TO
SOLID WASTE CENTER PORTANTINO
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS SB FORTY FIVE AS AMENDED
WITH EXPRESSLY DIRECT CAL
RECYCLE TO ASSIST LOCAL AGENCIES
IN IMPLEMENTING CALIFORNIA
ORGANIC WASTE REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDING MUSIC USING BUDGET
RESOURCES APPROPRIATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE UNDER CURRENT LAW
CHAPTER THIRTY ONE POINT ONE THE
STATE EVERY SAYS BOARDING CAL
RECYCLE REQUIRES LOCAL AGENCY TO
REDUCE EVENTUALLY ELIMINATE
ORGANIC MATERIAL SUCH AS FOOD
WASTE COMPOSTABLE AND OTHER
MATERIALS FROM DISPOSAL.
FACILITIES TO REDUCE METHANE
EMISSIONS FROM THOSE FACILITIES
BOTH CURRENT LAW AND THE TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET CONTAINS SIGNIFICANT NEW
DIRECTIVES IN FUNDING FOR THE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY INCLUDING
ORGANIC WASTE REDUCTION MORE
SPECIFICALLY THE BUDGET ACT
APPROPRIATED A HUNDRED NINETY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR CANNOCK
RECYCLING WITH SIXTY MILLION
ALONE FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
RECYCLING GRANTS THE BUDGET ALSO
CONTAIN A HUNDRED FIVE MILLION
FOR AGAMIC INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS
AN ADDITIONAL FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR COMPOSTING ORGANIC
WASTE SB FORTY FIVE WILL HELP
LOCAL AGENCIES GET THE
ASSISTANCE THEY NEED. FROM THE
STATE IN ORDER TO MEET STATEWIDE
ORGANIC WASTE LIMON FARMS THAT
NUMBERS ANY DISCUSSION DEBATE
THIS SIDE. ANY DISCUSS ORDER.
SEEING NONE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BAKER I
PORCHES I BRADFORD BY ADAM I
PROTECTING AYE DODD. I TORONTO I
EGGMAN AYE GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH I HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. I
HER TADO I JONES I KAMLAGER. I
LAYERED AYE LEYVA. I THE MON I
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ AYE NEWMAN
I NIELSEN. I ULTRA LIBERAL I CAN
. I PORTANTINO HI RON HI RUBIO I
SKINNER AYE STERN HI I'M BURKE
HI HI MY COUNTY AYE WIENER AYE
WILK HI. I S THIRTY SIX NINE
ZERO MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
MOVING NOW FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO
SENATE BILL THREE ZERO ONE BY
SENATOR SKINNER. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL THREE OH
ONE BY SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT
RELATING TO BUSINESS. CENTER
SKINNER THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. ORGANIZED
THEFT RING SEVEN TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF ONLINE MARKETPLACES
TO SELL STOLEN GOODS SB THREE OH
ONE IS PURPOSES TO MAKE THAT
LESS EASY IT REQUIRES LARGE
SELLERS TO ANNUALLY REPORT
VERIFICATION INFO INCLUDING
THEIR BANK ROUTING NUMBER AND
THEIR BUSINESS TAX DOCUMENTS.
AND IT MAKES THE ONLINE PLATFORM
PROVIDE A MECHANISM FOR US
CONSUMERS TO REPORT A SUSPECTED-
FRAUD OR ILLEGAL SALE OF AN
ONLINE GOOD. WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SENATOR NIELSEN YOUR
RECOGNIZE. THIS MAY BE COUNTED
AS A- WAIT STOP THIS TORRENT
TERRIBLE CRIME. THIS CRIME IS A
PRODUCT. A STATUTORY CHANGE. TO
WHERE PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN
THAT THE PEOPLE I'D ARGUE WERE
DEFRAUDED IN VOTING FOR. AND
THAT HAS INVITED THESE MASS
ROBBERS OF OUR STORES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. NOT TO WANT TO CHECK
AROUND THE ENGINE POUNDER
CHECHEN SAY GEE WE DID SOMETHING
. I GUESS THIS IS AN OKAY WAY TO
DO IT. BUT IT IS NOT THE ANSWER
. AND I WON'T DIGNIFY IT WITH
THE S. WILL I'M SIMPLY GOING TO
HAVE STATE UP STAIN IT IS A
PROBLEM. BUT IT'S A PROBLEM
CREATED SOMETHING FAR MORE.
SEVERE THAN THIS DEREK BILL WILL
EVER ASSIST. ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SENATOR SKINNER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU. ARM TO
BRIEFLY ADDRESS THE POINT MADE
BY OUR COLLEAGUE. AS WE'VE SEEN
MOST GOODS ARE SOLD ONLINE NOW-
WHETHER THEY'RE STOLEN FOR LEGAL
AND REALLY WHETHER IT'S
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT OR
ANOTHER MECHANISM DOESN'T MATTER
WHAT USED TO BE. BEING FENCED
OUT OF A TRUNK OF A CAR OR
PERHAPS AT A FLEA MARKET OR
SOMETHING. DOESN'T HAPPEN NOW
SOLD ONLINE BECAUSE PEOPLE BUY
THEIR GOODS ONLINE SO IF WE WANT
TO DISCOURAGE THE SALE OF STOLEN
GOODS. FROM ONLINE MARKETPLACES
THEN I WOULD URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU
CENTER SKINNER CENTERS CENTER
SKINNER THANK YOU. SECOND PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BAKER.
I FOR JUST AYE BRADFORD BY ADAM
I FOR. AYE DODD HI DURAZO HI
EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. FIVE HERTZBERG I WESTERN
. HI HER TADO. HURTADO I JONES I
KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE LEYVA AYE
LIMÓN. I MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ AYE
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. A CHOI BOGUE
I PAN. I PORTANTINO I ROTH HI
RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN AYE I'M
BURKE HI WHITE HOUSE SKI. I
WIENER HI WILK. THIS CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD NIELSEN
WILK. HIGHS THIRTY FOUR KNOWS
ZERO MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
MOVING ON A FILE ITEM SIXTY
THREE WHICH WILL BE FOLLOWED BY
SIXTY FOUR AND THEN SIXTY FIVE
FILE ITEM SIXTY THREE IS SENATOR
WIENER SENATE BILL THREE SEVENTY
NINE. SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
THEM SENATE BILL THREE SEVENTY
NINE BY SENATOR WIENER AN ACT
RELATING TO LAND USE CENTER
WIENER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES SB THREE SEVENTY
NINE- WILL REQUIRE JURISDICTIONS
ABOVE A CERTAIN SIZE TO
IMPLEMENT AUTOMATED ONLINE SOLAR
PERMITTING. FOR SIMPLE
RESIDENTIAL ROOFTOP. SYSTEMS AND
ALSO SOLAR PLUS STORAGE SYSTEMS
WATER COMMENTED THIS REQUEST IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET WE
APPROPRIATED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN GRANTS ARE FOR THE
ENERGY COMMISSION TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT
FOR CITIES AND IMPLEMENTING-
THIS. NEW PROCESS ARE CURRENTLY
ARE CALLING SOLAR PERMITTING CAN
BE VERY INEFFICIENT CAN TAKE A
LONG TIME- AND CAN INCREASE OFF
COSTS BY UPWARDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS- WHICH CAUSES A NUMBER
OF APPLICANTS TO DROP OUT OF THE
PROCESS. I ENTIRELY- AUTOMATED
ONLINE SOLAR PERMITTING ALLOWS
FOR SIMPLIFIED A MUCH MORE
EFFICIENT- SOLUTION BY ALLOWING
APPLICANTS TO APPLY IMMEDIATELY
DETERMINE- IF THEY'RE PROPOSED
SYSTEM IS CODE COMPLIANT. KERN
AUTOMATED PERMITTING SYSTEMS ARE
CAPABLE OF HANDLING FOURTEEN
TIMES THE NUMBER OF PERMITS A
TYPICAL METHODS- IN SAN JOSE FOR
EXAMPLE WHICH RECENTLY
IMPLEMENTED AN AUTOMATED SYSTEM
SALAS 6100% INCREASE AND PERMIT
APPLICATIONS. THIS INCREASED
VOLUME IS NOT A BURDEN ON
BUILDING APARTMENTS BECAUSE OF
THE SYSTEM IS AUTOMATED- AND- IT
WILL GENERATE MORE REVENUE- FOR
THEM TO BE CLEAR CITIES WILL
STILL HAVE THE PREROGATIVE TO
CONDUCT INSPECTIONS- BUT THIS IS
SIMPLY THE PERMITTING- ALTHOUGH
SB THREE SEVENTY NINE DOES NOT
MANDATE A SPECIFIC TECHNOLOGY OR
SYSTEM- THERE IS. ONE THAT WAS
BUILT BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY- BY THE NOT REVIEW ENERGY
LIVES- YOU AFTER A LONG
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS WE
ANTICIPATE THIS IS THE ONE THAT
MOST CITIES. WHAT IS NOT. SOUL
IS FREE CAN BE EASILY-
IMPLEMENTED- AND- IS A THERE'S A
LOT OF SUPPORT IN TERMS OF
MAKING SURE THE CITY PARKS ARE
GOING. ON HOW TO DO IT. OVER
FIFTY JURISDICTIONS ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF EVALUATING THE
SOFTWARE- MODESTO MENIFEE
OCEANSIDE PLEASANT HILL OR
VARIOUS STAGES OF ADOPTION. L.
A. AND SAN JOSE HAVE ALREADY
ADOPTED- AND SO THIS IS THE
TREND THAT SB THREE SEVENTY NINE
WILL NOT PUSH US IN THE RIGHT.
DIRECTION OTHERS CURRENTLY NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU CENTER WE
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSS OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SENATOR HERTZBERG
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR. SERENA
REJECTS OF THE QUESTION YES
CENTERS FOR. YOU KNOW WHAT. FOR
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY HUNDREDS
OF DAYS WHEN YOU WATCH BILL
MAHER'S TELEVISION SHOW I THINK
IT'S AN H. P. R. IN WHICH
ANALYSTS ON THE COMPLAINT SHOULD
SHOW AS TO HOW LONG IT TOOK HIM
TO FINALLY GET SOLAR APPROVED ON
HIS HOUSE MY QUESTION TO THE
AUTHOR TO YOUR KNOWLEDGE WITH
THIS MEASURE HAVE FIXED THAT
PROBLEM. WIENER I THINK I
VAGUELY RECALL OF THE BILL-
MORE- HIS EXPLANATION I DON'T.
COMPLETELY REMEMBER IT I CAN'T
REMEMBER THERE ARE TWO MAJOR
DELAYS ONE OF THEM IS THE
PERMITTING PROCESS. ON ONE OF
THEM WHICH IS STILL DOES NOT.
DEAL WITH IS THE INTERCONNECTION
PROCESS AND- PG&E AND OTHER
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES
SOMETIMES SIGNIFICANTLY DELAYED
TURNED LETTING YOU TURN ON. THE
SEPARATE- ISSUE BUT ON THIS ONE-
IT MAY. HAVE BUT I JUST DON'T
REMEMBER WHAT HE SAID THE EXACT
OPPOSITE WHEN WAS. THANK YOU ON
MY OWN TIME JUST VERY BRIEFLY I
THINK THAT- I'M NOT SURE IF IT
WAS INTERNET CONNECTION ISSUE OR
A PERMITTING ISSUE BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS. THAT WHAT'S
IMPORTANT AS WE- EMBARK ON NEW
AREAS OF ENERGY WE IT POLICY WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE. WE DO IT IN
THE MOST INTELLIGENT EFFICIENT
WAY TO INSPIRE CONFIDENCE IN THE
PEOPLE THAT WE HAD GOVERNMENT
NOTED THAT WE'RE DOING. AND SO I
SUPPORTED THIS IN COMMITTEE I
STAND ON THE FLOOR TODAY TO
SUPPORT AGAIN. IT'S AN IMPORTANT
STEP FORWARD IN THIS. DIFFICULT
TRANSITION WE- THIS WORK. OF
YOUR READING. THE AUTHOR FOR.
PAST I BOUGHT. THANK YOU SIR
HERTZBERG MAYBE WE CAN CONVINCE
MISTER MARK TO- TESTIFY IN THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES. ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THAT ITEM
IN THE DISCUSSION OF. SEEING
NINE SENATOR WIENER WOULD LIKE
TO. THIS PURPOSE MY ROOM THANK
YOU SEE WIENER SECRETARY FOR
KALRA. ALLEN I ARCHULETA HI AT
AYE BAKER. I FOR JUST. BRADFORD
CABRERA I PROTECTING I DODD.
FIVE TORONTO I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG I
WENT SO I HER TADO I JONES.
KAMLAGER I WHERE AYE LEYVA I
LIMON I MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ.
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NO A CHOI
BOGUE. HI PAN AYE PORTANTINO HI
ROTH I RUBIO. I'VE SKINNER. I
STERN HI I'M BURKE I WHITE HOUSE
E. AYE WIENER AYE WILK. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. PORGES
BRADFORD GROVE. JONES MELENDEZ
WILK. I HIGHS THIRTY ONE KNOWS
ONE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
MOVING ON A FILE ITEM SIXTY
THREE SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN. I'M SORRY FILE ITEM SIXTY
FOUR. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO FILE
ITEM SIXTY FOUR SENATE BILL
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN CENTER
PORTANTINO SECRETARY PLEASE READ
. SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR PORTANTINO AN ACT
RELATING TO PEOPLE HEALTH. CARE
PORTANTINO THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS WE NOW
CALIFORNIA IS IN THE MIDST OF A
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CRISIS.
AND IT'S BEEN EXACERBATED BY THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC WITH
DISTANCE LEARNING OUR YOUTH ARE
INCREASINGLY ISOLATED AND
DISENGAGED WITH DEPRESSION
SYMPTOMS AT AN ALL TIME HIGH FOR
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS. ACCORDING
TO US DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES NEARLY ONE IN
THREE CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS SURVEYED REPORTED
FEELING SAD OR HOPELESS ALMOST
EVERY DAY. FOR TWO OR MORE WEEKS
IN A ROW NEARLY ONE IN FIVE
REPORTED THAT THEY HAVE
SERIOUSLY CONSIDERED ATTEMPTING
SUICIDE. TEACHERS AND SCHOOL
STAFF FROM THE FRONT LINES OF
THIS CRISIS AS SUCH MUST BE
TRAINED TO IDENTIFY AND HELP
STUDENTS WHO ARE SUFFERING.
RESEARCH SHOWS US THAT THE
SOONER PEOPLE GET HELP FOR
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
CONCERNS THE MORE LIKELY WE ARE
TO HAVE A POSITIVE OUTCOME. THIS
BILL IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER
BECAUSE THE SCHOOLS ARE
TRANSITIONING TEACHERS ARE
ENCOUNTERING BEHAVIOR HEALTH
ISSUES RESULTING FROM EMOTIONAL
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC ON THEIR
STUDENTS. THE REALITY IS THAT
WHEN STUDENTS RETURN TO SCHOOL
THEIR TRAUMA AND DEPRESSION
RETURNS WITH THEM IF WE DON'T
REIN. PRINCE AND IT MANAGED. WE
WITH ALL THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO
HAVE BY DE. A CRY. A LACK OF
TRAINING DOESN'T KEEP STUDENTS
PRESSURED OR SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISORDERS AT HOME. WHILE
EXISTING LAW BECAUSE UPON THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO I DON'T. BUT IN IS
MEANT. GRAMS IT DOES. TOOLS THE
PROGRAM AFTER AND STARTED THIS
CON. AND I WANT TO THANK HIM FOR
HIS LEADER ON THIS ISSUE AND HIS
CAN TO. AT PEDIATRICIAN. STAND
BY THIS IS IMPORTANT OUR KIDS
AND FRANKLY THE SENATE
UNDERSTANDS WHY THIS IS
IMPORTANT FOR KIDS IN THIS BILL
HAS PASSED THIS HOUSE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE PAST
AND FRANKLY I'M GONNA KEEP
INTRODUCING IT EVERY SINGLE YEAR
UNTIL IT GETS ON THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK. SB THREE EIGHTY SEVEN
HELPS ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM BY
REQUIRING BY REQUIRING
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO ENSURE THAT 75% OF
FOLKS WHO WORK ON OUR CAMPUSES
ARE TRAINED. MANDATING EVIDENCE
BASED TRAINING WILL X. WILL
PROVIDE ESSENTIAL INSTRUCTION ON
HOW STUDENTS TEACHERS AND SCHOOL
STAFF. CAN BEST PROVIDE
REFERRALS AND HELP FOR OUR
CHILDREN LET'S BE CLEAR. THIS
TRAINING DOES NOT ATTEMPT TO
TURN STAFF OR TEACHERS INTO
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS IT
SIMPLY TEACHES AN INDIVIDUAL HOW
TO SPOT WHERE THERE'S A PROBLEM
. IN FACT I SEE THIS JUSTICE CPR
OR FIRST AID TAKING A FIRST AID
CLASS DOESN'T MAKE YOU A MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL IT JUST MAKES YOU
BETTER PREPARED TO HELP SOMEBODY
IN NEED. DURING OUR HEARING LAST
YEAR A FATHER CALLED IN AND
TALKED ABOUT HIS FOURTEEN YEAR
OLD DAUGHTER. WHO TURNED IN HER
JOURNAL ASSIGNMENT IN ENGLISH
CLASS AND GOT A NAY. AND THEN
TWO WEEKS LATER KILLED HERSELF.
AND THE FATHER SAID I DON'T
BLAME THE TEACHER BECAUSE THE
TEACHER WASN'T TRYING TO SEE THE
WARNING SIGNS OF SUICIDE IN THAT
JOURNAL. BUT FRANKLY GOING
FORWARD THAT TEACHERS SHOULD BE
TRAINED. TO SEE THE WARNING
SIGNS I KNOW STAFF AND
ADMINISTRATORS TO WORK ON OUR
CAMPUS SHOULD BE TRAINED. TO SEE
THE WARNING SIGNS OF MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES IN OUR
CHILDREN. AND I'M TIRED OF
HEARING AND SEEING PUSH BACK.
THAT'S ANTI TRAINING WHEN OUR
KIDS ARE IN SUCH DIRE NEED AND
SO COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD AND WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION UNTIL
IT GETS ON THE GOVERNOR'S DESK
AND GET TO SIGNATURE. THANK YOU
CENTER PORTANTINO CENTER RUBIO
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR ARCHULETA
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I ALSO STAND HERE AND
VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN- I WANNA TACKLE
EVERY SINGLE THING THAT A GREAT
CENTER FROM WALKING OUT OF STATE
IT AND I CAN SHARE. AS A EXPERT
TEACHER SEVENTEEN YEARS I THINK
IS ME INSIDE S. TO WHAT WE DEAL
WITH. OUR I NGUYEN WEARING
CLASSROOMS AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I OFTEN SAY IS THAT- WE'RE
EXPECTED TO TEACH WHICH WE DO
WELL BUT- THE OTHER ELEMENT IS
THAT WERE EXPECTED TO BE
COUNSELORS MENTORS
PSYCHOLOGISTS. AND TO BE ABLE TO
DO ALL THESE THINGS THAT WE ARE
NOT EQUIPPED TO DEAL IN FACT. I
WOULD ARGUE THAT NOW THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH THIS PANDEMIC
ISOLATION. AND PERSONAL STORIES
THAT I HEAR FROM MY TEACHER
COLLEAGUES. THERE PERSONALLY
STRUGGLING WITH WITH ISSUES OF
MEAN DATA TEACHERS ARE
STRUGGLING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENING THERE STRUGGLING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW TO TEACH HOW TO
CAPTURE THESE KIDS THAT ARE
COMING AND TRAUMATIZED. STRAZ
AND EVERYTHING ELSE THAT COMES
WITH WHAT WE'VE BEEN
EXPERIENCING THE PAST TWO YEARS
AND I THINK THAT THIS IS JUST A
SIMPLE WAY. OF SAYING TO
TEACHERS WE CARE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU'RE WELL EQUIPPED
TO BE ABLE TO DEAL WITH THIS
TYPE OF CRISIS ON OUR HANDS SO.
I WILL SAY AGAIN BOB WITH
EXPERIENCE IN THE CLASSROOM WE
DON'T HAVE THE EXPERTISE. ON
HAVE BEEN UP BY H. AND WE ARE
STRUGGLING OFF TO TAKE. THESE
KIDS ARE DEALING WITH SOMETHING
MORE THAN WE CAN DEAL WITH ARE
WHEN I HEAR THAT ONE IN FIVE
ARE. THINKING OF ATTEMPTING
SUICIDE ONE IN FIVE. IS WAY TOO
MANY KIDS I WOULD SAY ONE IS WAY
TOO MANY KIDS BUT- I REALLY WANT
TO ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO
CONTINUE TO PUSH FOR THIS. I
REALLY HOPE THAT THE GOVERNOR
WOULD SUPPORT SOMETHING LIKE
THIS AND I STRONGLYURGE
EVERYONE ELSE UP TO VOTE I THINK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER RUBIO
SENATOR ARCHULETA. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I SHOULD ALSO STAND
STRONG SUPPORT. OF SB THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN. AND I WILL TELL
YOU THIS. THAT WHEN I'VE HAD MY
ROUND TABLE DISCUSSIONS WITH
BOARD OF EDUCATION MEMBERS AND-
AND COUNSELORS AND SCHOOL
TEACHERS IN MY DISTRICT- THE
SUBJECT OF MENTAL HEALTH WILL
ALWAYS COME UP. HOW BETTER SURE
REPRESENT OUR STUDENTS. AND ALL
WE'RE ASKING IS THAT WE GIVE THE
TRAINING AND- THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THOSE WHO LOVE AND TAKE CARE
OF OUR CHILDREN. TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE AND THE
SKILL. TO KNOW WHEN SOMETHING IS
WRONG. HOW DO WE KNOW AND MOST
WERE TRAINED. AT THE SENATOR
MENTIONED ABOUT FIRST AID HOW DO
WE KNOW HOW TO TREAT AND LESS
WERE GIVEN THE TRAINING. AND I
THINK THIS IS WHAT WE'LL NEED-
TO TAKE IT ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WERE CALIFORNIA. WILL
LEAD AND PROTECTING AND SERVING
THESE KIDS EVERY SINGLE DAY. WE
HEAR ABOUT GANG VIOLENCE WE HEAR
ABOUT. IT THE CITIES- HAVING
ISSUES WE HEAR ABOUT IT ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
REGARDLESS OF THE ECONOMIC
STATUS OF THE CHILDREN THE
SCHOOL. IT IS A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS AND THE CANNABINOID HAS
NOT HELPED. IN THE ONLY WAY WE
CA HELP IS TO GIVE THE
RESOURCES AND THE TIME THE
EFFORT. TO THOSE IN THE
EDUCATIONAL INDUSTRY. TO BE ABLE
TO BE WELL TRAINED WELL SUITED
TO BE ABLE TO SPOT IT. PICK UP
THE PHONE CALL SOMEONE. GOT
SOMEBODY WE CAN SAVE LIVES THIS
WEEKEND ARE WE GONNA PREVENTS.
SIDE YES WE CAN ARE WE GOING TO
MAKE BETTER STUDENTS ALL THE WAY
AROUND. YES WE CAN THIS IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY. I THINK THAT WE
SHOULD ALL GET TOGETHER. IN
TOTAL SUPPORT SB THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN. AND I ASK FOR I. HIS
LEADERSHIP AND ADVOCACY- AND- HE
REALLY HAS BEEN A- HUGE CHAMPION
FOR YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH AND-
FOR. IMPORTANCE OF SCREENING. I
WOULD POINT OUT AS HE'S
MENTIONED IN HIS REMARKS THAT
WE- STILL HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY HERE TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE. MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR YOUTH WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE TEACHERS HAVE A LOT
ON THEIR PLATE. AND THEY HAVE A
LOT OF THINGS THEY HAVE TO DO.
AND BUT THEY ARE INTERFACING
WITH THE STUDENTS IN A CLASSROOM
AND THEY ARE THE BEST PEOPLE TO
BE ABLE TO HELP IDENTIFY YOUTH
IN NEED HELP. BUT THIS WAS
MENTIONED. WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
TURN THEM INTO MENTAL HEALTH.
EXPERTS IT'S NOT THAT'S THEIR
JOB. TO HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO TREAT THEM AS WELL THE
INDEMNIFYAND THEN WE NEED TO BE
SURE TO SOME PLACE FOR THE THOSE
USED TO GO. AND SO OF COURSE I
RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT LAST
YEAR WE INCLUDED IN THE STATE
BUDGET FOUR BILLION DOLLARS FOR
YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH. AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT WE CONTINUE THOSE
INVESTMENTS. BUT THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT OBVIOUSLY WE'RE NOT
GONNA HAVE BY WE'RE NOT GONNA
HAVE ENOUGH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SPECIALISTS. TO SEND IN THE
CLASSROOM TO WATCH ALL THE
STUDENTS ALL THE TIME. RIGHT
TEACHERS ARE A IN THE CLASSROOM
BUT THEY CAN PICK UP THE SCIENCE
AND WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO WITH
THIS BILL. WE HAVE TEACHERS.
TRAINED TO BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY
THE SIGNS AND THEN WE NEED TO DO
OUR JOB TO BE SURE THERE
SOMEPLACE FOR THOSE USED TO GO
WHEN THE TEACHER SAID YOU KNOW
WHAT. I'M GONNA FIND YOU. OBLONG
THEY NEED HELP. AND WE ARE BE
SURE TO HELP IS THERE. SO BUT
INTEL BUT WITHOUT THAT FIRST
STEP. WE'RE GONNA HAVE ANOTHER
GAP. IN TERMS OF OUR YOUTH
GETTING HELP AND SO THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL ADDRESSES AND I'M
STANDING IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
AGAIN I REALLY WANT TO THANK MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM LIKE THE AUTO
FOR. HIS ADVOCACY IS LEADERSHIP.
AND WHILE- APPRECIATING GIVE ME
CREDIT FOR STARTING THIS SEASON
WAS GONNA TAKE THIS OVER THE
FINISH LINE AND I HOPE YOU WILL
HELP THEM DO THAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO SENATOR STERN FOLLOWED
BY SENATOR EGGMAN. SENATE STERN
. THANK YOU. I READ DRAW
SUPPORTER THIS MEASURE AND I
WOULD SORT OF I WOULD ADD TO THE
CONVERSATION- THERE WHEN WE DO
SPOT. THESE PROBLEMS BEFORE THEY
ARISE. WE DO NEED TO SERVICES IN
PLACE AND WE'VE WE'VE TAKEN IT A
SHOT AT ONE TIME FUNDING IN THIS
SPACE. ABOUT THE SURGEON GENERAL
NOTED THAT THIS IS NOT A PROBLEM
THEY WILL JUST GO AWAY NEXT FOR
NEXT YEAR. WE PUT FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS I THINK TO
SUPPLEMENT ELEAZAR LAST YEAR IN
THE BUDGET. BUT UNTIL THE HEALTH
INSURANCE SPACE STARTS TO
INTEGRATE ITSELF INTO THE
EDUCATION SECTOR. AND ACTUALLY
PROVIDE THAT MENTAL HEALTH CARE
UP FRONT. AN OFFSET THOSE
PRESSURES THAT ARE ON OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS RIGHT NOW IT'S STILL
WE START TO SYNERGIZE. I THINK
WE'RE GONNA HAVE. A LOT MORE
PROBLEMS THAN WE REALIZE BUT THE
FIRST STEP IS BRINGING SOME
LIGHT TO THE SITUATION AND THANK
GOD FOR SCHOOL TEACHERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS AND EVERYONE ELSE
OUT THERE WHO HOPEFULLY WILL BE
OUT THERE IS WATCHERS ON THE
WALL TO HELP CATCH PEOPLE BEFORE
THEY FALL SO THANK YOU. THE
CENTER FROM WALKING OUT OF
FRANKLIN RIDGE BUT I HOPE THIS
COMMITS US TO A DEEPER
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT THE
LINES ARE TO BE OR LACK THEREOF
BETWEEN SCHOOLS. AND OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER STERN CENTER EGGMAN
WILL BE FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
DRAWS OF SENATOR EGGMAN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON THIS
FINE BILL- I WORKED ON THIS A
LITTLE BIT A COUPLE YEARS AGO AS
WELL AS SOME EW FROM MY
DISTRICT ASSEMBLY ON THE SCHOOL
BOARD. AND DOES A LOT OF WORK
WITH KIDS PRODUCTS THIS IDEA
ABOUT MEDICAL OR MENTAL HEALTH
FOR STATE IS A FANTASTIC IDEA WE
JUST HEARD FROM. SENATOR FROM
SAN FRANCISCO THIS LAST WEEK
ABOUT RABBIS HAVING TO GET
TRAINED IN BEING ABLE TO DE
ESCALATE SITUATIONS
UNFORTUNATELY IN THIS DAY AND
AGE WE ALL HAVE TO GET CROSS
TRAINED IN OFTENTIMES. CLERGY
ARE PART. ARE THE FIRST ONES ON
SITE FOR ALL KINDS OF
EMERGENCIES THESE DAYS. THEY
HAVE ACTIVE SHOOTING. TRAINING
NOW THERE'S NO REASON THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE MEDICAL OR MENTAL
HEALTH FIRST AID AT THE SAME
TIME. WELL WITH SOMEONE NEW HOW
TO DO CPR WE HAD A HEART ATTACK.
JUST LIKE THAT WE ALL WISH
SOMEBODY WAS THERE TO BE ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE. SIGNS AND SYMPTOMS OF
OUR KIDS ARE HAVING TROUBLES IN
SCHOOL. I WOULD SUPPORT THIS
BILL RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL. THANK YOU SIR EDMUND
CENTER DORADO. THANK YOU- I KNOW
AS SOME OF US. SOMETIMES WE
DON'T. PREPARE AND THINK WE'RE
GOING TO GET UP AND SPEAK BUT-
AFTER HEARING THE AUTHOR ON
DESCRIBED THIS. IT REALLY-
BROUGHT CAME TO MY ATTENTION SO.
I'M DEFINITELY. GOING TO SUPPORT
THIS BUT- I WANT TO ADD THAT
IT'S A MATTER OF HOW WE USE OUR
RESOURCES WHEN IT COMES TO
PUBLIC SAFETY. ARE THERE A LOT
OF CONCERNS ABOUT HOW PUBLIC
SAFETY USES. THE FUNDING THAT
THEY GET BUT I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANY DOUBT THERE'S NO
DOUBT IN MY MIND. WHEN IT'S THIS
EXPLICIT THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. TRAINING AND TEACHING AND
LEARNING A DIFFERENT WAY. OF
APPROACHING ISSUES AND PROBLEMS-
THAT'S A GOOD THING FOR ALL OF
US SO I URGE AND I WILL. THANK
YOU SENATOR RAZA MEMBERS ANY
OTHER ANYMORE DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CENTER PORTANTINO HAD
LOTS OF COMMENTS AND SUPPORT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I THANK
MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR SUPPORT
AND APPRECIATED AND CERTAINLY
OUR CHILDREN APPRECIATED AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. YOU CENTER PORTANTINO MEMBERS
THIS QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR. ANY
OBJECTION. SEEING NONE IS THIRTY
SIX KNOWS ZERO MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING ON TO FILE
ITEM SIXTY FIVE. WHICH IS SENATE
BILL FIVE THIRTEEN SENATOR
HERTZBERG SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTEEN BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AN ACT
RELATING TO HOMELESS SHELTERS
SENATORS BURKE. THEY MUST
PRESIDENTIAL. THIS GOVERNMENT IN
CALIFORNIA OUR GOVERNOR AND THIS
LEGISLATURE IN BOTH HOUSES IF
AUTHORIZED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO FIGHT HOMELESSNESS. WITH
PASSED NUMEROUS BILLS TO FIGHT
HOMELESSNESS AND NEARLY 24% OF
OUR COUNTRY'S HOMELESS
POPULATION RESIDES IN CALIFORNIA
A HUNDRED FIFTY CALIFORNIA FIFTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS ARE
HOMELESS ON ANY GIVEN NIGHT. SO
THE CALL POSTED BY THIS BILL.
WHICH WE DID IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AGAIN LAST YEAR. WHAT
IS WHAT IS GOING ON THE STREET
AND WHAT CAN WE DO THAT'S
THOUGHTFUL AND INTELLIGENT THAT
HELPS GET FOLKS OFF THE STREET.
IN CONVERSATIONS THAT I'VE HAD
WITH A NUMBER OF FOLKS. WHO FIND
THEMSELVES HOMELESSNESS HE SAID
I'M NOT GOING TO SHELTER WITHOUT
MY PET. EIGHT HAPPENING.
ACCORDING TO THE NONPROFIT
FEEDING PETS FOR THE
HOMELESSNESS ESTIMATED 15225% OF
AMERICANS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OWN A DOG OR CAT IN
SOME INSTANCES OTHER ANIMALS
THAT I'VE SEEN. AND SO WHAT WE
DID IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WAS
TO INCLUDE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE BUDGET- TO STAND UP THE
PET ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT
PROGRAM AND IT WAS IMMEDIATELY
OVERSUBSCRIBED. DRAMATICALLY
LAST YEAR THE GOVERNOR APPROVED
IN THIS LEGISLATURE SUGGESTED
TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
SIMILAR PROGRAM. THE MEASURE
BEFORE YOU TODAY BUILDS ON THE
SUCCESSES OF THE PET ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM AND PUTS IN THE SYSTEM
THE PROGRAM PERMANENTLY INTO OUR
STRUCTURE OBVIOUSLY EVERY YEAR
WILL HAVE TO MAKE AN
APPROPRIATION. BUT AS WE DEAL
WITH THIS EXTRA. HOMELESSNESS
IMPORTANT TO FIND THOSE AREAS
WHERE THE IMPACT IS
EXTRAORDINARY THE COST IS LESS
AND THE ANSWER IS HUMANE FOR
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR GROWTH.
THANK YOU A MISTER PRESIDENT I
AS I'M GONNA SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY BECAUSE I THINK THAT- MY
COLLEAGUE. IS VERY CORRECT ON
THE FACT THAT ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT FACE. HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
IS THAT THEY HAVE NO PLACE FOR
THEIR PETS IN THE SHELTER THE
GOVERNOR AUTHORIZE FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN THE STATE BUDGET LAST
YEAR THIS YEAR IS EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS ACCOUNTED TO ADDRESS THE
HOMELESS POPULATION. AND
HOMELESS POPULATION INCREASES
WHEN IT 28% IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES MYSELF AND MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES HAS ASKED
THE GOVERNOR FOR A SPECIAL
SESSION TO ADDRESS THE HOMELESS
ISSUE BECAUSE WE THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED AS- THE HOMELESS ARE
LEAVING AND NOT ONLY JUST
BECOMING MORE IN OUR STATE- WE
HAVE 13% OF THE NATION'S
POPULATION AND 47% OF THE
HOMELESS- AND SHE- POPULATION.
AND WE'VE ASKED FOR A SPECIAL
SESSION TO ADDRESS THIS
INDIVIDUALS ARE BECOMING MORE.
IN THE- MORE. DOWN THE STREET
EVIDENT WITH YOU SEE STOOD ON A
THAT WAS STABBED TO DEATH WAS
WAS WORKING PART TIME AT A
FURNITURE STORE ALLEGEDLY BY A
HOMELESS PERSON YORK CITY
ALLEGEDLY A HOMELESS PERSON
THREE SOMEBODY ON TO THE TRAIN
TRACKS SO WE DO HAVE TO ADDRESS
ALL CAPACITY OF THE HOME
SITUATION NOT JUST HOUSING FIRST
BUT MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE- THE BENEFIT OF
SINGER APERAM SERVICES MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES ADDRESSED AND DRUG
ADDICTION SPECIFICALLY. THIS
BILL REMINDS ME OF A STORY THAT
HAPPENED IN MY DISTRICT JUST
LAST YEAR WE TOOK IN MORE
VETERAN ON THE STREET AND- I HAD
MET HIM AND I GOT STAFF ON IT
RIGHT AWAY AND WITHIN THREE DAYS
I SAID CAN YOU DON'T HAVE A
PLACE FOR THIS PERSON YOU KNOW
WE PAID FOR A HOTEL PERSONALLY
NOT. PAIN OR ANYTHING AND-
ANYBODY GET THE WRONG IDEA
ANYWAYS- FOR THREE DAYS THAT
WOULD TAKE HIS DOGS AND WE
COULDN'T FIND IN HOUSING WE
COULDN'T GET HIM INTO A LOCAL
SHELTER BECAUSE HE DID HAVE AN
IN THEIR TIME OF THE STILL. WITH
HIS ANIMALS AND WHEN I TO HIM
HE'S I LOS MY LIFE THEY TOOK MY
HOME. AUGUST THE ONLY FAITHFUL
THAT I'VE IN MY LIFE FOR. THE
LAST FOUR YEARS. THIS IS
SOMEBODY WHO PICKED UP A WEAPON
TO DEFEND THIS COUNTRY AND
FOUGHT FOR FREEDOM IN KOREA. SO
I KNOW THAT HE'S JUST A SMALL
EXAMPLE OF. THE COUNTLESS
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE OUT THERE
THAT THIS BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER GROVE
MEMBERS ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM FILE ITEM
SIXTY FIVE. ANY OTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SAN HERTZBERG WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AS FERNANDO. THE CENTURY
MEMBERS THIS QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NO OBJECTION HIS THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS
WE'RE GONNA GO ON TO FILE ITEM
SIXTY SIX AND THEN BACK IN THE
FILE TO ADAM FORTY FIVE. WHICH
WILL BE OUR FINAL ITEM WE HAVE
SEVERAL ITEMS ON CALL- SO IF
EVERYBODY CAN BE PRESENT FOR THE
NEXT SEVERAL VOTES THAT WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL. FILE ITEM SIXTY
SIX THE CENTER PORTANTINO SENATE
BILL FOUR EIGHTY FIVE SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FOUR
EIGHTY FIVE BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY CENTER
PORTANTINO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS SB FORTY
FIVE IS A SIMPLE EXTENSION OF
THE CURRENT ENTERTAINMENT TAX
CREDIT FOR FIVE ADDITIONAL
YEARS- IF YOU'VE BEEN WATCHING
IN THE NEWS YOU WILL SEE THAT
OUR ENTERTAINMENT BUSINESS
OBVIOUSLY IT WAS CHALLENGED BY.
COVERT TEAM BUT IT BACK IN
FORCE. AT CAPACITY AND A BIG
REASON WHY THAT'S THE CASE IS
BECAUSE THIS LEGISLATURE IN THE
PRO TEM UNDER HER LEADERSHIP
WHEN SHE WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY-
PUT TOGETHER A TAX CREDIT.
PACKAGE TO HELP THE INDUSTRY IT
IS WORKING LAST YEAR WE PASSED.
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO NOT JUST
. X. THE SHORT FOR IN THE
CURRENT TAX CREDIT BUT TO CREATE
ADDITIONAL INCENTIVES TO BUILD
MORE STUDIO. SPACE IN CALIFORNIA
AND I WANT TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT
TO OUR BUDGET CHAIR FOR WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT HAPPENED AS WELL.
BECAUSE THE MORE CAPACITY WE CAN
GENERATE THE MORE MIDDLE CLASS
JOBS WE CAN CREATE. AND WE
TYPICALLY GET CRITICIZED FOR NOT
FOCUSING ON MIDDLE CLASS JOBS.
THIS TAX CREDIT WILL CREATE AND
KEEP AND EXPAND. MIDDLE CLASS
PRODUCTION JOBS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS WHERE THEY
BELONG NOT IN OTHER STATES OR
OTHER COUNTRIES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO SENATOR WILK. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I STAND AS A CO
AUTHOR OF S. B. FOR- FORTY FIVE
WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR FROM
WALKING OUT OF MY REACH FOR
THIS. THIS IS MORE THAN JUST AN
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT BILL. THIS
IS A QUALITY OF LIFE BILL YOU
WHEN I'VE WAS FIRST RUNNING FOR
THE LEGISLATURE BACK IN TWENTY
TWELVE. I HAD A LOT OF MEET AND
GREETS IN PEOPLE'S HOMES. AND
INVARIABLY THEY WERE SOMEBODY
THERE. AND THEIR SPOUSE WAS OUT
OF THE STATE. I REMEMBER BEING
AT A AT AT B. GREET IN CASTAIC
WITH THIS WOMAN CRYING ON MY
SHOULDER HER HUSBAND WAS A
CAMERAMAN FOR MOVIES. HADN'T
DONE A MOVIE IN CALIFORNIA. IN
SIX YEARS. I REMEMBER MEETING
WITH A DOCUMENTARY FILMMAKER HE
WAS GONE FOR SIX MONTHS THE YEAR
PRIOR. AND HE MISSES LONERS FOR
DAY. PEOPLE WE SEPARATED DIVORCE
OCCURRED BECAUSE PEOPLE WENT OUT
OF STATE. IT DOESN'T TAKE A LOT
TO ENTICE THIS INDUSTRY TO STAY
HERE IT WAS BORN HERE IT'S AN
ICONIC PART. OF CALIFORNIA
CULTURE AND I'M SO EXCITED THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GET CONTINUE THIS
AND I WILL TELL YOU. HIS FIRST
HAND THIS IS THIS IS MORTGAGE
PAYING JOBS THAT THIS BILL
CREATES CAUSES FOR THAT THOSE
PEOPLE BELOW THE LINE. AND IT'S
PHENOMENAL AND ENCOURAGE
EVERYONE TO SUPPORT THE SENATORS
EFFORTS THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR WILK CENTER DORADO. YES
THERE ARE AGAIN ONE OF THANK THE
AUTHOR- THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT- ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
IN OUR STATE- AND I WISH THAT MY
DISTRICT HAD A LOT MORE OF THE
PEOPLE WHO WORK IN THIS IN THIS
INDUSTRY BECAUSE- ON. IS A GOOD
UNION JOB INDUSTRY AND I THINK
THAT REALLY NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THAT THIS INDUSTRY THE
DENSITY OF THE NUMBER OF WORKERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES THE REASON
THAT SMALL BUSINESSES AND OTHER
BUSINESSES ARE SO DEPENDENT ON
THEM. BECAUSE THEY BRING HOME A
GOOD PAYCHECK THEIR PENSION PLAN
THEY HAVE GOOD THINGS IN THEIR
LIFE TO LOOK FORWARD TO SO THIS
IS AN INVESTMENT IN THEM IT'S IN
THE BEST OF IN THE INDUSTRY IT'S
AN INVESTMENT ON FOR THE WHOLE
STATE AND- I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK- THAT
THERE'S GONNA BE A- THAT THERE
IS A COMMITMENT. THAT THESE JOBS
WOULD BE OPENED UP. TO
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
HIRED IN THE PAST AND- WITH THAT
COMMITMENT I'M SURE THAT FARM
ANYMORE CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO
HAVE THE ECONOMIC ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY THAT THEY DESERVE
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR. THANK
YOU SENATOR DRAWS A SENATOR
STERN. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
RISE VERY BRIEFLY AS A CO AUTHOR
JUST TO BUILD ON- MY SENATE
CALLING FROM LOS ANGELES IS
POINT I THINK IF WE HAVE A
LONGER TIME HORIZON. ON THIS
PROGRAM THANK YOUNG PERSONS
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN YEARS OLD
GROWING UP. IN WHATEVER PART OF
CALIFORNIA THEY MAY BE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY OR SANTA CLARITA
VALLEY OR ANY STILL LATER
WHEREVER IT IS. SEES THAT THIS
WON'T BE A YEAR TO YEAR DEBATE
IN THIS LEGISLATURE THAT WE KNOW
THIS INDUSTRY IS BACKBONE FOR
OUR ECONOMY AND SO I THINK
GIVING IT THIS HORIZON IS
ACTUALLY WHAT. WILL MAKE THIS
PROGRAM LEE- AVAILABLE FOR
EQUITABLE. TIMES WE WANT TO SEE
AND MAKE THIS INDUSTRY A PLACE
FOR EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA SO.
EIGHT RIGHT AND WHAT COALITION
BUILDER AND- I THINK WE'RE GONNA
GET IT DONE THIS YEAR TO AT THE
INDUSTRY NEEDS US RIGHT NOW IT'S
NOT THE PEOPLE ABOVE THE LINE SO
WHEN I WAS GRINDING OUT THERE
EXACTLY AS RIVAL THANK YOU
CENTER STERN MEMBERS ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SENATOR
EGGMAN. THANK YOU FOR IT YOU
KNOW PEOPLE OFTEN THINK OF THE
CENTRAL IS A PLACE FOR FILMS-
AND WE'D LIKE TO CERTAINLY. HAVE
THAT EXTENDED ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THE STATE AND LOOK
FORWARD TO IT STOCKTON WAS ONCE
THE HOME OF A LOT OF FILMMAKING.
THINK BACK COOL HAND LUKE. ALL
THE PRESIDENT'S MEN. INDIANA
JONES SERIES ALL SHOT IN AROUND
THE STOCK IN AREAS OF COURSE.
AMERICAN GRAFFITI THAT WE ARE
ALL AT THE VERY WELL AND
YOURSELF I ALSO JOIN IN MY VOICE
TO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ON SB FORTY FIVE. THANK
YOU CENTER EGGMAN ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE CENTER PORTANTINO WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AGAIN THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES FOR ALL OF THE CO
AUTHORS IN JOINT AUTHORS IN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. SAN FORTINO
MEMBERS THIS QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NO OBJECTION HIS THIRTY SIX
KNOWS ZERO MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING BACK IN THE
FILE TO FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE
SENATE BILL FIVE SIXTY SENATOR
RUBIO. SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE SIXTY BY
SENATOR RUBIO AN ACT RELATING TO
ENERGY. SERAPEUM THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL FIVE SIXTY
WHICH AIMS TO IMPROVE THE PUBLIC
HEALTH LOW INCOME AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES BY
ESTABLISHING A CLIMATE POLLUTION
REDUCTION IN HOMES INITIATIVE.
HISTORICALLY OUR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES HAVE
DISPROPORTIONATELY SHOULDER THE
BURDEN OF POOR AIR QUALITY AND
HIGHER ENERGY COST FOR EXAMPLE
TWELVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
WITHOUT ACCESS TO PROPERLY
VENTILATED APPLIANCES ARE
ROUTINELY EXPOSED TO NITROGEN
DIOXIDE LEVELS IN THEIR HOMES
THAT WOULD EXCEED FEDERAL AND
STATE HEALTH BASED STANDARDS. IF
FOUND OUTSIDE THE HOME
CONSIDERING THE LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS SPENT AN AVERAGE OF
FOUR POINT 5% OF THEIR MONTHLY
INCOME ON ENERGY BILLS ANY COST
SAVINGS THAT STATE CAN OFFER
WHAT WITH THEM WILL IMPROVE
TECHNOLOGY AND THEIR HOMES. AND
WILL HAVE A MAJOR IMPACT ON THE
ECONOMIC SECURITY OF THESE
HOUSEHOLDS A GRANT PROGRAM LIKE
THE ONE IDENTIFIED IN THIS BILL
ALLOWS LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES TO
BE AT THE FOREFRONT OF CLIMATE
CHANGE BY MAKING DIRECT IMPACTS
TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASES IN
THEIR HOMES. THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO. MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE
ANY DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BAKER. I PORCHES. BRADFORD
CABALLERO HIGH COURT TESTING I
DODD. I TORONTO I EGGMAN I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE WESSEL I FURTADO I
JONES NO KAMLAGER. I LAYERED AYE
LEYVA AYE LIMÓN HI MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ. NEWMAN I NIELSEN BY A
TROUBLED. HI PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO HI SKINNER I
STERN HI I'M BURKE I WHITE HOUSE
HE AYE WIENER AYE WILK HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BORCHERS BRADFORD GROVE I
MELENDEZ. HIGHS THIRTY THREE
KNOWS ONE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE FILE
THE ITEMS ON CALL WE HAVE TO
ITEMS ON CALL I FILE ITEM THIRTY
FIVE IN FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE WE
CAN PLEASE LIFT THE CALL ON FILE
ITEM THIRTY FIVE. PORGES
BRADFORD GLAZER I HER TADO I.
MELENDEZ NO NIELSEN NO STERN HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
PORGES BRADFORD HIS TWENTY NINE
IT KNOWS IT'S SIX MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE MOVING A FILE ITEM
FIFTY FIVE ALSO ON CALL.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BRADFORD GROVE I. MELENDEZ.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD MELENDEZ. HIGHS THIRTY
THREE KNOWS TO MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO TAKE UP
THE CONSENT CALENDAR MANY MANY
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FOR FORTY. DOES ANYBODY
WISH TO PULL AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SING NINE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I'M SORRY- IT'S UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL MEASURE PASSES HIGHS THIRTY
SIX NOS ZERO. MEMBERS ARE MOVING
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
. THIS IS GONNA BE THE TIME IN
OUR SESSION THAT WE TAKE UP
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY WE'RE
GOING TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR
GLAZER FIRST FOR JOHN MADDEN
SENATOR GLAZERS. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I WOULD
REQUEST THAT THE SENATE
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF JOHN
MADDEN THE HALL OF FAME COACH OF
THE OAKLAND RAIDERS AND LONGTIME
FOOTBALL ANALYSTS WHO DIED
RECENTLY AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY
FIVE. MISTER BAD WAS RAISED IN
DALY CITY. LATE FOR CAL POLY SAN
LUIS OBISPO IN NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN AND NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT.
EARNED HIS BACHELOR'S AND
MASTER'S DEGREES. A KNEE INJURY
SIDELINED HIS PRO PLAYING
DREAMS. BUT PUT HIM ON THE PATH
TOWARDS COACHING. HIS FIRST
SIGNIFICANT JOB WAS AT SAN DIEGO
STATE UNIVERSITY AS THE
DEFENSIVE COORDINATOR. MADDEN
LIVED IN MY DISTRICT IN
PLEASANTON FROM THE TIME YOU
STARTED COACHING THE RAIDERS IN
THE LATE NINETEEN SIXTIES.
RESTARTED THE CAR ABOUT HIS
LEGACY AS ONE OF THE NATIONAL
FOOTBALL LEAGUE'S PREMIER
WINNERS. HIS WINNING PERCENTAGE
OF SEVEN POINT SEVEN FIVE NINE
IS THE HIGHEST IN THE HISTORY OF
THE NATIONAL FOOTBALL LEAGUE.
WHICH IS TO HAVE COACHED IN MORE
THAN A HUNDRED GAMES. HE LED THE
RAIDERS TO SEVEN AMERICAN
CONFERENCE FOOTBALL TITLES WON
THE SUPERBOWL IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX. BUT YOU COULD SAY
THAT HE HAD AS MUCH OR EVEN MORE
OF AN IMPACT. AFTER HE RETIRED
AT THE AGE OF FORTY TWO FROM THE
SIDELINES. REMEMBER MADNESS STOP
COACHING BECAUSE OF HIS FEAR OF
FLYING. AND LATER HAD HAD HIS
OWN TOURING BUS TO TAKE HIM.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO GAMES HE
ANALYZES THE TV COLOR MATCH. HE
WON SIXTEEN EMMY AWARDS FOR
OUTSTANDING SPORTS. ANALYSIS
COVERED ELEVEN SUPER BOWLS FOR
NETWORKS IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE TO TWO THOUSAND NINE.
MISTER BAD HAD A WAY OF MAKING
HIS POINT. REMEMBER IS
DESCRIPTION OF THIS TACKLER THAT
BLOCK LAP WHAM BOOM. HE BECAME A
HOUSEHOLD NAME BECAUSE OF HIS
MAVERICK STYLE OF ANALYZING THE
GAME FANS ACROSS THE NATION FELT
A KINSHIP. TO THIS BURLY
SLIGHTLY RUMPLED AND
UNPRETENTIOUS MAN WITH A BIG
GRIN AND LOADS OF PLAIN TALK HE
ATTACKED THE TELESTRATOR LIKE IT
WAS ON A CHALKBOARD A LOCKER
ROOM WITH AXES AND HOES AND
ARROWS DIAGRAMMING PLAYS WE JUST
SEEN. HE INVENTED A NEW
THANKSGIVING MEAL THE PRODUCTION
. WHICH HE'D GET TO THE TOP
PLAYERS OF THANKSGIVING DAY
GAMES. BUTTER DUCK AND BY THE
WAY WAS THE CHICKEN STUFFED
INSIDE OF A DUCK STUCK INSIDE OF
A TURKEY. WHICH YOU LOVE
TELESTRATOR. A FOOTBALL VIDEO
HIS NAME BECAME ONE OF THE MOST
POPULAR IN THE NATION. MOSTLY
BECAUSE OF ITS REALISM AND IT
HAD HIS STAMP OF APPROVAL. SOME
OF YOU IN THE BAY AREA MAY HAVE
GOTTEN UP EARLY ON A MONDAY
MORNING JUST TO LISTEN TO HIS
RADIO SHOW. IN WICHITA GREAT AND
HILARIOUS TALES OF HIS CAREER
JUST MAKE POINTED OBSERVATIONS
ABOUT SUNDAY NFL GAMES ARE ABOUT
LIFE. IN GENERAL. WHEN PEOPLE
ASK ARE YOU A COACH OR A
BROADCASTER. OR A VIDEO GAME GUY
. MISTER BAD WOULD SAY I'M A
COACH ALWAYS BEEN A COACH. AND
HE WAS A COACH FOR ALL OF US I
WANT TO EXPRESS MY SYMPATHIES TO
JOHN'S WIFE VIRGINIA ROOM JOHN
JUST RECENTLY CELEBRATED THEIR
SIXTY SECOND WEDDING
ANNIVERSARY. AND TO HIS THREE
SONS JOSEPH MICHAEL AND JOHN
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
WE TURNED HIS GREAT MEMORY TODAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
GLAZER SENATOR COM LONGER FOR
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER WILLARD H.
MURRAY JUNIOR. CENTER COME UNDER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THIS
AFTERNOON I ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF THE
HONORABLE WILLARD H. MURRAY
JUNIOR FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MURRAY WAS BORN ON JANUARY
THIRTY FIRST NINETEEN THIRTY ONE
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
PRIOR TO SERVING IN THE
LEGISLATURE MR MURRAY WAS AN
INCREDIBLE ENGINEER. AND UNITED
STATES AIR FORCE VETERAN HE WAS
ALSO A PROMINENT CIVIL RIGHTS
ACTIVIST IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
WHICH ULTIMATELY LED TO HIS
ESTABLISHED CAREER IN PUBLIC
SERVICE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARIE
WAS ELECTED TO THE CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT REPRESENTING. THE SOUTH
LOS ANGELES. FIFTY SECOND
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT HE SERVED AS
LEGISLATURE THIS LEGISLATURE FOR
EIGHT YEARS DURING HIS TENURE.
MR MURRAY SERVED AS A PAST CHAIR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS AND CHAIR THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE ON
STATE ADMINISTRATION.
LEGISLATIVELY HE WAS DEDICATED
TO REPRESENTING HIS
CONSTITUENTS. ON POLICIES
SURROUNDING EDUCATION CRIMINAL
JUSTICE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
HEALTH CARE. UPON HIS DEPARTURE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY.
THE HONORABLE MR MURRAY
CONTINUED HIS AMAZING WORKS OF
PUBLIC SERVICE BY SERVING ON
BOTH THE BOARD OF THE WATER
REPLENISHMENT DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THE
BOARD OF THE METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF CALIFORNIA. HE SPENT
HIS YEARS IN THE WATER INDUSTRY
ADVOCATING FOR RELIABLE SOURCES
OF CLEAN AND SAFE WATER FOR
RESIDENTS IN THE REGION. AND
CHAMPION THE WATER INDEPENDENCE
NOW PROGRAM. FOR SOUTH LA.
THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE. MISTER
WILLARD H. MURRAY MADE
INCREDIBLE STRIDES TO HELP HIS
COMMUNITY AND WAS A REMARKABLE
LEADER AND PUBLIC SERVANT I
EXTEND MY DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO
HIS FAMILY ESPECIALLY TO FORMER
SENATOR KEVIN MURRAY WHO
REPRESENTED THIS DISTRICT WHICH
I CURRENTLY REPRESENT. MEMBERS
OF HIS FORMALLY REPRESENT
COMMUNITIES AND EVERYONE THAT
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK AND
ENGAGE. AND LEARN FROM SUCH AN
EXCEPTIONAL MAN. MADE THE
HONORABLE WILLARD MERRY REST IN
POWER IN MAY THE MEMORY OF HIS
LIFE SERVICE AND ACCOMPLISHMENTS
LIVE ON. THANK YOU SIR
COMMERCENTRE HERTZBERG ON THIS
ITEM IS VERY BRIEFLY I DIDN'T
UNFORTUNATELY AND REALIZE THAT-
WILL BE PASSED. ON HE WAS
MISSING FELLOW I WORK SIDE BY
SIDE WITH HIM ON THE STAFF OF
BERMAN M. DONNELLY WHEN HE WAS
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FORTY WORK FOR THE
SENATE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN
THOSE DAYS HE RAN A COLORFUL
ORGANIZATION CALLED THE
COMMUNITY DEMOCRATS SELF LOS
ANGELES THAT ALL OF US INVOLVED
IN THE COMMUNITY THAT TIME WERE
QUITE AWARE OF. AND HE LEFT THIS
LEGISLATURE WHEN I CAME IN SOME
TWENTY SIX YEARS AGO- THE SUN
THE- SO PRETTY INCREDIBLE GUY
KEVIN AND YOU KNOW I WORKED ON
WHEELER'S CAMPAIGN I CAN'T WHAT
YEAR THAT WAS THE THINK THAT.
CIRCUMLUNAR MENTIONED IT BUT YOU
KNOW IT'S HARD TO SEE THE
PASSING OF SOME OF THESE GREATS
WHO BEEN INVOLVED IN SO MANY
THESE FIGHTS WHO SHOULDERS SO
MANY OF US STAND ON WHOSE NAMES
WE DON'T REMEMBER SO AS SOMEONE
WHO IS A VERY YOUNG BOY AT THE
TIME. WORKING AROUND THESE FOLKS
LISTENING AND LEARNING- KEEP MY
MOUTH SHUT AND TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS GOING ON. HE
WAS ALWAYS QUITE INSIGHTFUL AND
COLORFUL AND INTERESTING. AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY PASSION
COMMITTED TO JUSTICE. AND I.
WHEN WE JOURNALISTS MEMORY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG. NEXT IS SENATOR PAN FOR TYLER
TIGHTENING AND- SIR PAN THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT- SENATORS- I
SADLY RISE TO TURN IN THE MEMORY
OF ELK GROVE POLICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICER TYLER LENAHAN THE SIX
YEAR OLD GROVE POLICE VETERAN.
ALSO LENAHAN WAS KILLED BY A
DRUNK DRIVER DRIVING THE WRONG
WAY ON HIGHWAY NINETY NINE-
SOMEONE WHO CHOSE NOT TO COMPLY
. WITH OUR DRUNK DRIVING LAWS
AND TRAFFIC LAWS- SOFTER LENAHAN
WAS- GOING TO THIS POST- LAST
FRIDAY AND HE DIED AT THE AGE OF
FORTY FOUR. HE SADLY THE FIRST
ULTRAVOX OR WHO'S EVER HE'S BEEN
KILLED IN THE LINE OF DUTY.
SINCE THE FOUNDING OF THE CITY.
OCELLATA HAN WAS A VETERAN HE
SERVED FIVE YEARS IN THE U. S.
AIR FORCE PRIOR TO BEGINNING HIS
CAREER IN LAW ENFORCEMENT TWENTY
TWELVE AS A RESERVE OFFICER FOR
SIX DIFFERENT HEIGHTS. POLICE
DEPARTMENT. HE THEN WORKED FOR
TWO YEARS AT THE GULF POLICE
DEPARTMENT BEFORE JOINING THE
OAKLAND POLICE DEPARTMENT AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN. PARTICULAR
MOTORCYCLE OFFICER- JUST AND
TWENTY TWENTY. ALSO ON HAND WAS
A PERSON IS COMMITTED TO SERVING
HIS COMMUNITY THOSE CLOSE TO HIM
DESCRIBED HIM AS A BRIGHT LIGHT
PERSONALITIES WILL BE DEEPLY
MISSED. SOUTH SIDE OF BEING A
COMMITTED OFFICER TO OUT TO THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY ALSO IN HOUSE
ALSO DEDICATED TO SERVING HIS
FAMILY AND CHURCH COMMUNITY. HE
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE JESSICA
WHO IS A POLICE OFFICER WITH THE
SACRAMENTO POLICE DEPARTMENT AND
THE- TWO CHILDREN AUSTIN AND
SYDNEY THIS PARENTS AND THREE
SIBLINGS. TODAY REMEMBER OFFICER
LENAHAN FOR HIS COMMITMENT. TO
PROTECT BOTH THIS COUNTRY AND
THIS COMMUNITY. AND WE SEND OUR
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO HIS
FAMILY AND FRIENDS THANK YOU.
CENTERS IF YOU'LL PLEASE BRING
THE NAMES FORWARD- TODAY SO THEY
CAN BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. I
APPRECIATE THAT. MEMBERS IF
THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
CENTER MCGUIRE THE DESK IS CLEAR
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A PRESENT A
NICE JOB TODAY MEMBERS
PRODUCTIVE DAY VERY GRATEFUL THE
NEXT COURT SESSION IS SCHEDULED
FOR THIS WEDNESDAY JANUARY
TWENTY SIX AT TEN AM ENTER THE
REST OF THE EVENING. THANK YOU
SIR MCGUIRE MEMBERS THE SENATE
HAS ADJOURNED WE WILL RECONVENE
ON WEDNESDAY AT TEN AM THANK YOU.